it really is hard to imagine a more
bizarre or gruesome injury
than what happened to cake boss star
buddy valastro
he impaled his dominant baking hand in a
freak bowling accident
and buddy joins us now how are you
holding up
definitely uh trying to stay positive
still recovering
um the the hand is okay i mean
there's definitely a lot of pain you
know it's just a freak crazy thing
bowling is a way of life this is the
bowling alley inside the cake boss's new
jersey
home where the freak accident happened
last week but he was playing with his
sons when the pin setter got stuck
and he went to fix it i must have you
know turned my head for one moment
and then there was like this fork that
held my hand in place
as this mechanism went through my hand
it was blood everywhere i was
i was in panic mode but something told
me to stay calm
the cake boss's right hand was
repeatedly impaled by a two inch thick
metal rod
for over five minutes until his older
two sons use the saw to free their dad
you instructed them on what to do it did
honestly i couldn't be prouder of my
sons and my family
the longer that rod was in my hand the
longer a chance that i could have lost
my hand
if it would have hit my wrist forget
about i could have bled out how long do
they think the recovery will be
it's definitely going to be months i
might need more surgeries
it shattered my thumb the 43 year old's
already had two procedures on the hand
he used to build his estimated 10
million dollar baking empire
i might not ever be able to pipe again i
don't know
you know i i mean unfortunately i might
have to learn to do with my other hand
um you know you just don't know kev for
now
buddy is resting at home check out the
new recliner set up but
he desperately wants to get back to work
listen i plan on going into work in a
week or so
i mean i can't in a week come on no i
mean
at least go check in thank god my mouth
still works so
i could talk and uh and dictate take
some time off let the hand heal brother
you got it kev i appreciate it
you